hello everyone
i'm christy risk senior editor at
genomeweb and i'll be your moderator
today
the title of today's session is
harnessing the power of the xp protein
expression systems in vaccine
development this e-case study will start
with a brief presentation
and will follow up with a q a discussion
with our panelist
our panelist today is dr roland leathers
senior
strategic alliances for the europe
middle east africa
and asia pacific regions at thermo
fisher scientific
dr leathers will be speaking about what
makes the xp systems unique
and how they can be used in the
development of vaccines
special thanks to our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for making this
presentation possible
dr leathers please go ahead uh christy
thank you very much indeed for the
introduction
hello ladies and gentlemen and thanks
for joining us for this presentation
since the beginning of this year we've
all been witness to the global
coronavirus outbreak
which has now taken pandemic proportions
researchers have quickly responded to
the outbreak of this novel coronavirus
and using techniques such as next-gen
sequencing and crayon
cryo-electron microscopy have already
determined the viruses genomic sequence
as well as its 3d structure armed with
this information
considerable efforts are now being put
into the development of recombinant
vaccines
to be able to protect global populations
from disease
and ultimately bring disease progression
to a halt
at the same time other groups are
developing serological tests
that will enable the detection of the
presence of the anticode 19 antibodies
in the serum of patients
to better understand the degree of
patient exposure to infection
and to make assessments of population
immunity
both recombinant vaccine production and
serological test development
have a requirement for high quality
recombinant
coronavirus antigen in this presentation
i would like to take a look at how
we can harness the power of the xp
protein expression systems
to produce recombinant antigens for the
development of vaccines and serological
tests
so let me start with what is protein
expression now naturally i'm sure that
you're all very much aware of what
protein expression is
but i think this serves as a good
reminder that cells are factories
and in protein expression we are simply
exploiting a cell's ability
to produce protein and re-tasking it to
produce our desired protein of interest
which in this case will be the various
coronavirus antigens
that will have been genetically encoded
into an expression construct
the efficiency of the protein expression
system will ultimately determine
both the yield and the quality of the
expressed
proteins so if we put this into the
vaccine researcher
what are the needs with regard to regard
to recombinant protein expression
systems
well certainly the expression system
must have the ability to
produce vaccine candidates rapidly
certainly during the exploratory phase
of vaccine development we need to be
able to produce and
uh evaluate numerous candidates
and then we as we progress them we would
like to shorten the time
to clinic equally we need to be able to
produce higher yield of protein
again during the exploratory phases
we're after high yield because typically
we're working with low culture volumes
and so we need to make
functional assessments of the proteins
being produced
having pre-generated our candidate
vaccines one then needs to be able to
scale manufacturing
quickly and cost effectively
so here's an overview of the vaccine
development workflow
you can see the exploratory phases the
developmental phases and the
manufacturing phases here
over on the left-hand ci side we see
pathogen identification
followed by a candidate vaccine panels
which will have been generated based on
sequence information from the virus
itself
having screened panels of candidate
vaccines and selected appropriate
candidates for further development
frequently groups will then go on to
make a stable expression cell lines from
those candidates
the stable cell lines will be further
evaluated and eventually
used in pilot scale manufacturing for
potential clinical
evaluation assuming that clinical
evaluation is successful
after various rounds of evaluation the
candidate will be moved into large-scale
manufacturing
so where do our xp systems fit into this
workflow
well certainly our xp transient
expression systems
fit very nicely into the screening of
candidate vaccine panels
but you will also see later in this
presentation
that we now offer you a path with the xp
systems through to
from transient expression through to
trade a stable cell line generation
makes these xp systems unique
um these xp systems are complete systems
they are fully optimized systems uh each
component in the system has been
optimized individually and both as a
system using design of experimentation
approaches
each system comprises cells
and these cells have been selected for
their high specific protein productivity
in all cases they are grown as single
cell spensions
so cell suspensions at very high cell
densities
the media systems are all chemically
defined animal origin free
and manufactured under cgmp principles
each system has its own unique
transfection reagent
we need to achieve high transfection
efficiency at high cell density
and so we've had to develop new
transfection reagents for that purpose
the systems are also provided with
expression enhancers and feeds to
further boost expression
and of course we can also provide
expression vectors of which we have a a
whole family of vectors that can be used
for
uh expression in the xbxp systems
interestingly each xp system is also
provided with what we call a technical
control
so that you can ensure that the systems
are functioning optimally in your
laboratory
prior to actually introducing vaccine
candidates into the expression system
that i would now like to take a look at
some of the exp
xp systems that are available to you and
the first system i would like to
describe
is the so-called xb293 expression system
which is a mammalian cell-based
expression system
that uses a heck 293 cell line
now this system enables the rapid
development of vaccine candidates
and generates high yields of protein
typically in the system we have seen up
to one gram per liter
of protein being produced in transient
transfection
and again this is an integrated system
meaning that all of the components of
the system have been individually
optimized
as well as the system itself the
components of the system are the xb293f
cells which have been adapted to high
density suspension culture
the chemically defined expression medium
which is transfection compatible as well
as the unique transfection reagent used
to transfect your constructs of interest
into the high-density cell lines
hotel cultures
the second x i would like to describe to
you briefly
is the xp cho expression system
this is also a mammalian expression
system that uses a cho
s cell background for expression this
system provides a high yield
end-to-end platform enabling a faster
time
to clinic when used in transient mode
we see yields of protein up to three
grams per liter in the system
it's also imp importantly that this
system uh provides you
with just one cell line that you can use
all the way from
discovery through to the the clinic
this means that your exploratory work
can be done using our research use only
exp cho s cell line
exploring vaccine candidates but as you
progress them through to development and
eventually through to manufacturing
you can work with our cgmp banked cell
line
either in transient mode or to produce
stable cell lines
for more clinically relevant work and of
course this is very important being able
to use the same cell line throughout the
development process because it enables
you to maintain protein quality
and function throughout the entire
workflow process
the xp chose system similar to the 293 f
system
comprises the cells which have been
again adapted to high density cell
suspension culture
the chemically defined animal origin
free expression medium
the novel transfection reagent that
allows transfection of these high
density cell cultures
a technical control this is the antibody
expressing positive control
again enabling optimization of the
system in your lab
prior to actually expressing your own
constructs the optipro
serum free medium for complexing
the dna vectors that will be transfected
into the cell
background as well as exp cho stable
production media
which is a media formulation that's been
developed specifically should you decide
to take
your constructs into stable cell lines
so i'd really like to to just to
reinforce
um that there is an easy transition from
performing uh
transient work uh through to performing
stable work with the exp cho
system the on the left hand side you see
the complement of
xp cho transient tools
which are research use only but should
you decide to progress
candidates towards the clinic you can
switch to our cgmp banked
exp cho s cells along with our stable
production medium
which provides you a very nice
transition from exploratory work through
to development
and again through to the clinic and
again this is really the main benefit
here is that you can
maintain the quality and the function of
your protein
from early exploratory work through to
development and manufacturing
so in the next slide i've really
overlaid our vaccine development
workflow diagram that you saw previously
to show you where the exp cho systems
will be used so
and typically we're seeing that the exp
cho transient systems are being used in
the screening
of antigens these are the vaccine
candidates uh once candidates have been
selected for downstream progression
then groups will frequently switch to
our expicho
stable platform uh enabling stable cell
line generation in a cgmp bank cell line
clinical grade manufacturing of pilot
batches of vaccine for evaluation
and eventually through to large-scale
manufacturing
the third i would like to describe is
the xbsf
expression system this is an
insect based expression system that uses
the sf9 cell background
and it provides a cost-effective
solution for vaccine discovery
interestingly in head to head studies we
see that this system outperforms
all existing insect platforms with at
least three-fold higher yields of
protein
this is also uh the first insect
expression system that uses a chemically
defined medium
there are no yeast delayed presence in
in this medium and we also provide the
system with express enhancers to further
boost
expression by working with chemically
defined media of course we can ensure
that we have
consistent cell growth and consistent
protein expression yields
run after run the ability to actually
make
macular virus in a cell suspension
cultures
means that we have a very short times
from construct to protein
so there are no there is no requirement
for viral amplification
using the xbsf system which means that
we are
already generating protein from
constructs within six to ten days which
is approximately half that
of most other expression systems uh
insect expression systems
uh the components of this system
comprise again the xbsf9 cells which
have been adapted to
high density cell suspension culture the
chemically defined media
an enhancer a protein expression
enhancer a
transfection system for transfecting
back mids into the sf9 cells
the back-to-back expression system
the dh10 back competent cells
for generating the recombinant back mids
as well as the optimum reduced serum
medium
used for complexing dna prior to
transfection
the final part of this presentation i
would just like to introduce you briefly
to two case studies
the first here describes the work of dr
keith chapel
at the university of queensland in
australia dr
chapel is part of the coalition for
epidemic
preparedness innovations otherwise known
as sepi
and in their work following acquisition
of
viral sequence information from patient
samples
the the group have gone on to design
expression constructs using the
university of queensland's
so-called molecular clamping technology
which maintains the natural 3d structure
of the
expressed antigen throughout the work
the dr chapel has been performing
the xp cho system has been used as the
system of choice
because it provides fast high yields
and quality protein if you are
interested in
understanding more about the use of the
xp system in dr chapel's work
i'd like to refer you to the recent a
publication that's cited at the bottom
of this slide
in the second case study i'll be
describing briefly the work of dr jiang
zhu
at the ins at the scripps institute in
la jolla uh california
whose team are developing vaccines
against hiv this time
during the course of dr zoo's work
they've used extensively the xp
cho system to express native like
trimers and g
for 140 nanoparticles and they found
that the xp
cho system allowed them to improve both
the yield and the quality of the gp
140 nanoparticles if you're interested
in understanding more about the use of
the xp
cho system in dr zoo's work again i'd
like to refer you to the citation
at the bottom of this slide
i've introduced you to three xp
expression systems
firstly the xb293 transient expression
system which uses a heck 293
suspension cell line to provide high
yields of protein
up to one gram per liter secondly the
exp cho system which uses a cho
suspension line for transient expression
work
with yields of up to three grams per
liter but the system also provides a
path
through to the clinic through the
provision of a cgmp
banked cell line that can be used to
generate stables for development
and biomanufacturing work finally the
xbsf system for generating high yields
of protein from an insect cell line
maintained in a chemically defined yeast
elite free
medium for reproducible uh expression
performance
if you'd like to know more about any of
these systems then please refer to the
web
web link below or contact your local
firm official
representative thank you very much
thank you roland let's start the q a um
so how do the protein yields from the xp
cho expression system compare with from
freestyle cho
or the xp293 system
um thank you christy well working with
various test proteins
from different protein classes the exp
cho
expression system was found to yield
between 25
to 160 fold more protein than the
freestyle cho
expression system and we see between two
to four
fold more protein than the xb293
expression system and do i need to
change media after transfection
in the xv293 and xp chose systems
uh no you don't in fact so that was one
of the the design prerequisites of these
projects so the media systems
in both the xb293 and the xp cho system
have been designed to be transfection
compatible and there is no requirement
to change the media
uh post transfection can the xp systems
be used to express things that could
then be used in the clinic
the culture media and the transfection
reagents used in the xb293 and xp cho
systems and in fact as well as the xbsf
system
are all chemically defined animal origin
free
and all manufactured under cgmp
each of these systems is provided with a
cell line for
research use only however we also have
cgmp banked master banks for the xb 293
and the xp cho cell lines so for those
groups seeking to express protein for
downstream use in the clinic
we are able to provide a complete and
fully cgmp compliant expression system
along with the documentation that will
be required by the regulator
and how cost effective are the xp
systems for expressing proteins of
interest
well all three xp systems the xb293 xp
cho and xbsf
represent the highest yielding
expression systems available in the
market today
and would normally be expected to
provide you with the lowest cost
milligram of protein
that you have probably ever produced
how many days of culture acquired before
harvesting protein with the xpsf system
uh well depending on the particular
protein being expressed
the harvest time will typically between
day 6 and day 10 post transfection
harvest time is typically a parameter
that we would recommend should be
included as part of your expression
optimization
process as it can impact protein quality
we typically find that the whole process
of generating bachelor viral stocks
through to harvesting protein is roughly
half that of other bachelor viral
systems available today
and this is because we're able to
eliminate the need for viral
amplification steps
prior to initiating our expression runs
thereby significantly reducing the time
it takes
to generate protein from novel
constructs
and where can i find additional engine
on the xp systems
well for additional information i can
refer you to
thermofisher.com forward slash protein
expression in one word
otherwise please take contact with your
local thermo fisher representative
great thank you very much we'll wrap it
up there we'd like to panelist roland
leathers
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
thank you all for joining us for this
session
you